you can't sit
still you can't sit still and know that
you don't
exist you can't sit still and not move
and recognize that the thing that is
looking out your eyes is nothing it's
Freedom it's emptiness it's wholeness
your everything everywhere all the time
you've never left it you can't possibly
leave it it's for forever it's a done
deal it's complete it's here now and
Timeless absolutely Beyond yet supremely
present to the mundane and
ordinary here it is you can't possibly
leave it it's
this hearing my voice speaking these
words it's
this and because you're avoiding voiding
that you're running like a chicken with
your head cut off like a separate
individual into a world of other
separate individuals that all have
competing agendas to try to get
themselves the most money
resources women material objects
Weaponry just mutually sure
destruction all because there's been a
complete overlooking of what's already
empty and whole and free and Love and
You